this is the common denominator and I'm
Elana Rachel
[Music]
Daniel welcome back to the common
denominator I'm Elana Rachel Daniel we
are here today with Robert Spencer he's
the director of jihad watch and a
shillman schillman fellow at the David
Horwitz Freedom Center he's the author
of 28 books including the New York Times
bestsellers the politically incorrect
guide to Islam and the Crusades and the
truth about Muhammad the bestsellers as
well the history of jihad from Muhammad
to Isis and the critical Quran explained
from Key Islamic commentaries and
contemporary historical research his
forthcoming book is Muhammad a critical
biography Spencer has led seminars on
Islam and Jihad for the FBI the United
States Central Command United States
Army command and general staff College
the US Army's Ace symmetric Warfare
group The Joint terrorism task force the
Justice Department's anti-terrorism
advisory Council and the US intelligence
Community he's discussed Jihad Islam and
terrorism at a workshop sponsored by the
US state department and the German
foreign Ministry he is a senior fellow
with the center for security policy
Spencer's a regular columnist for PJ
media and front page magazine and
written many hundreds of articles in G
about Jihad and Islamic terrorism
his articles on Islam and other topics
have appeared in countless platforms
across a vast gamut of media sites and
journals he's also served as a
contributing writer to the investigative
project on terrorism and as an adjunct
fellow with the free Congress Foundation
Spencer's appeared on a staggering list
of news talk shows and radio channels
from BBC to CNN to the mark Levan show
he's been featured speaker at
universities and institutions from Penn
State to Westminster Institute all the
above a far lengthier list than we can
name all here his depth of expertise and
quality of research has guided curious
audiences across every spectrum of
public and private discussion that can
be held the purpose of our conversation
is not to Aha Islam or cherry-pick
problematic passages of another Faith
nor to call it out as lesser Jews
worldwide see Tick Tock versions of
their own tmu deliberately maligned
daily ours is not a conversation
removing quotes from its framework but
rather the defining of that framework
and context itself we pursue coherence
in this critical period where the issues
that directly affect our lives have
never been made more distorted and
contrite and weaponized to confuse
divide and conquer us we know the method
well and we're tired of it where to look
at challenges in the eye and call them
aloud by name reins down an ingenuous
ingenuous clutching of pearls and
censorship of speech for it threatens
the hypocritical behavior and policy of
the Absurd that decays the West at this
moment our world has fundamentally
changed it's vital that we understand
what's driving it it's critical that we
absorb not engagement farming headlines
but the more complex and messy roots of
the ideologies that drive those changes
precisely as is our aim for the Jewish
perspective in Israel we will arrive at
no Clarity nor ability to affect it
without understanding the motivations of
the forces that prog ress them we are
living in a world where Islamic
terrorism threatens 9 million people and
the entirety of the state of Israel but
hardly us alone it threatens the 90
million Iranians who Roar out of their
Chokehold with the death of the Butcher
of Iran former President Abraham REI
this week and it threatens the Free
World in its entirety and the Civil
civilization on which it was built that
means you and me
both the religious ideology that defines
the Islamic Republic of Iran for example
along with their proxies inas heah the
houthis and their many many various
branches is foreign to us on an
elemental level in increasing frequency
we witness acts of savagery that we do
not wish upon our worst enemy acts that
go against not only our Myriad of
cultures but go against the humanity
which we believe to be shared by us all
Robert Spencer you are most welcomed
thank you greatly for taking the time to
join us today and help us understand
what the civilization we so cherish
faces so that we might act decisively to
keep it alive thank you very much I'm
honored by your
invitation so let's just start off in
brief um you uh tell us how and why did
you get involved in this work uh and how
have you managed to stay with it for so
long if I'm correct 1980 you began your
research yeah that's right uh I was
actually it's the roots of It Go back
farther than that to uh the 1960s
because that was when I was very young
and I would hear stories from my uh
grandparents particularly my grandmother
about life in chesme in what is now
turkey and at the time she was growing
up the Ottoman Empire and she would tell
us how uh beautiful it was how she loved
to hear the Islamic call to prayer in
the morning she was not Muslim but she
would she and Barack Obama are the two
people in the world who say that it's
the beautiful sound and uh she uh to
Painted life there when she was growing
up as a an idilic paradisal thing so
then of course that led to my inevitable
question as six or seven years old why
did you leave and she said we were
exiled why were you exiled and that was
always the end of the discussion so I
was always curious as to what was the
reason that my grandparents left there
and came to the United States and that
led me to begin to study the history of
the region and ultimately it came to me
that this was all about Islam and this
was at around the time when I was in
college in 1980 indeed and started to
read the Quran because as it turned out
they were given the choice to convert to
Islam and stay there where their
families had lived from time immemorial
or leave be exiled and so they left and
my great-grandfather was murdered on the
way out but the rest of them were able
to get out
and it was all about the in the first
place the Islamic cleric's idea that the
religious minorities in this region were
kufar hary infidels at war with Islam
because they had they wanted their
independent states you know the the
Greeks had independence from
1823 and there were all the Greeks in
Western Anatolia who wanted an nois
Union with the Greeks in Greece and then
there were the Armenians in the east
eastern part of Anatolia and they wanted
their own State and so they were both
rebelling against the lawful Islamic
Authority which an Islamic law means
they could be killed and
so there was this is the occasion of the
genocide of two and a half million
Armenians and a million Greeks and
300,000 Assyrians and this is of course
the
basis on which
the genocides of the 20th century
precede because of course hajam Mina
husseini the Muti of Jerusalem was in
the ottoman
military when the genocides were taking
place and then he went to Berlin and
lived during World War
II meeting with Hitler meeting with
himler friends with ikan visited a
concentration camp some people even have
asserted that he gave plans for gas
chambers that the Turks had had
developed for the
Armenians to the Germans I don't know
the extent of the truth of that but
there's no doubt that Al husseini of
course agitated for
the end of the immigration of the Jews
of Europe and the beginning of their
being Mass murdered and this was the
occasion for Hitler's statement well
whoever remembers what happened to the
Armenians nobody cares
and so and of course nobody even
mentions that there were Greeks involved
as well not only does nobody care about
that nobody even knows about it
so anyway all this led me into the UN
trying to understand the theological
principles within Islamic tradition that
could lead people to behave in this way
because that was the underpinning of all
of it now a lot of people will note that
the Turkish nationalists continued this
and completely eradicated with the
exception of a very tiny minority that
remains in Istanbul completely
eradicated the Greek community of what
is now turkey that had been there since
the time of Homer you know and the
Trojan Wars and all that the uh Turkish
nationalists though had the idea of a
Turkish nationalist secular state that
included Islam as part of the identity
of a Turk with without the political
aspects of Islam and so there was still
no room for those who were not
Muslim well so for 35 years and even
longer you're searching for this
answer and it doesn't seem like it's um
it's such
a maybe I should say well have you
arrived at clarification after all of
this time um yeah yeah I would say that
I have full clarity now as to what
happened that it does have to do with
several principles that are rooted in
the Islamic religion that have to do
with things that are relevant to the
situation of the state of Israel as well
because
the Welter
in Anatolia at the time of the fall of
the Ottoman
Empire and the time that the Greeks and
the Armenians were trying to establish
their own independent states also gave
rise to groups that asserted that this
was Islamic land and consequently it
belonged to Islam
forever and that there was no legitimacy
to an Armenian state or a Greek State on
any of that land because it was
Islamic the idea is based on chapter 2
ver 191 of the Quran which says very
simply drive them out from where they
drove you out now if you think about
this statement it's a very brief and
simple statement but it's extraordinary
in its implications because it is saying
that if you are on land that the Muslims
once
occupied however legitimately or
illegitimately or by whatever means they
got it that's not relevant then it
belongs to them forever and they have a
Divine command from the Supreme Being
the creator of the universe to drive you
out of
it and keep take it back as breev said
in a very different context in 1968 when
the the the what was it the Prague
spring was in flower and a Kinder
gentler form of Soviet communism was
being exercised in
Czechoslovakia and breev sent in the
tanks and people were protesting and
saying how can you send tanks against
your fellow socialists and he said don't
talk to me about socialism what we have
we
hold and that that's the same principle
in Islam that's a quintessentially
Islamic principle what we have we hold
and
so the Greeks had to be driven out and
the arm Ians had to be driven out of
Anatolia and the Jews have to be driven
out of
Israel and the Spanish have to be driven
out of Spain there are plenty of others
on the to-do
list this is amazing because obviously
it couldn't be more relevant and I've
actually never heard
anyone reference it uh reference it to
actual the Quran and their actual
ideology because my understanding has
been
that the um the knba the the the tragedy
is not so much about the land it's their
inability to defeat the Jews the the the
weakest of the weak and that that where
it's a stain on the existence the fact
that it's a stain on their identity on
their religion on their relationship to
to Islam they're not able to defeat us
but it's not just because of weakness
it's because of who the Jews are in the
Quran chapter 5: 82 of the Quran says
the the most intense in
enmity of all people toward you will be
the
Jews and the polytheists and so the
polytheist part is not relevant here but
if the Jews are the most intense in
hostility toward the
Muslims then what that works out to in
practice is that the Muslims are the
most intense in hostility toward the
Jews and the
idea is it see you also have to
understand that within the context of
the fact that there is no room in Islam
for the idea that the wicked
Prosper all through the Hebrew
scriptures you have the psalmist
lamenting you know why do the wicked
prosper and the idea that defeat and
loss are sometimes part of what it means
to be God's
people but there is no concept of that
in Islam
in Islam it's a onetoone equation that
Allah will reward you in this world and
in the next if you obey him and Allah
will punish you in this world and in the
next if you if you don't obey him and so
if the Jews are the worst enemies of the
Muslims then humiliation and disgrace
must follow them and this is another
quranic passage
3112 follow them 21 289 and 3112
humiliation and disgrace must follow
them through throughout the world
because they are disobeying
Allah and so the idea of the umah the
global Islamic community being defeated
by people whose natural position in the
world rightful position in the world
according to the word of the Supreme
Being is to be humiliated and disgraced
and who are the worst enemies of the
best of people on Earth which is chapter
3: 110 of the Quran then you see it's
just a massive insult it's a tremendous
threat to the religion itself and this
is an aspect of the conflict that the
Western World universally ignores
because they don't take theology
seriously or think it could possibly be
relevant for political
action there's a few things that that
that questions I have from that so first
and foremost so if you're comparing Jews
with those who worship many gods so so
is it because they need to delegitimize
if they're to be the purveyor of a new
revelation is is that because it
shouldn't be at odds in in theory part
of the abrahamic type of religion one
God the the original um so why us
chapter 3: 67 of the Quran says the Jews
and Christians argue over
Abraham and they are both ignorant
Abraham was neither a Jew nor Christian
he was a Muslim now you might think how
Earth could Abraham be a Muslim when
Muhammad is seventh century CE and
Abraham is thousands of years before
that and see this is a very important
element of Islamic theology that is
virtually completely misunderstood in
the west and when people talk about this
the three great abrahamic religions
business they do not realize that
this is not the same
Abraham he has the
name but Abraham in Islam is an Islamic
prophet and so is Moses and so is David
and all the rest of them and so is Jesus
also and the idea is is that they all
taught
Islam and then their Craven and
self-serving and sinful rebellious
followers twisted their teachings to
suit their own purposes and in so doing
created Judaism and Christianity as we
know
them and
so the the real Jews are the
Muslims the real Christians are the
Muslims when they say our Allah and your
Allah are the same which is also the
Quran CH
29:46 they are talking about actually
meaning that the Jews and the Christians
are Renegades who have Twisted the
teachings of their own prophets to
create false religions and they are the
real
thing the correct version of the
teachings of Abraham and Moses and all
the rest of them
so we're all children of Abraham except
they're The Real Children of Abraham and
we're the fake
ones wow that's incred incredible
Insight I because of course spending any
time online and watching the inversion
of narrative and the unhinged hysteria
and all of that um recently someone was
posting around a picture of of a little
basket of Moses but like wrapped in a
you know CFA something along those lines
to show that that Moses was and I
thought this was just sort of like along
the lines of kind of you know sticking
it to the Jews type of thing I didn't
really think that didn't understand
there was a real belief behind that it's
very very tell uh telling it's um it's
of cardinal importance and it runs all
the way through Islam Islam is about
submission that's what Islam means
people tell you Islam means peace Salam
means peace Islam is a related word you
know how it works on the three consonant
just like Hebrew and so Salam and Islam
have share the same consonants and they
are related words but they're not the
same word and Salam is peace Islam is
submission now submission in the classic
sense is submission to Allah that every
human being has to submit to Allah but
also there are all kinds of other
submissions and one of them is I mean of
course there's women have to submit to
men but also non-muslims have to submit
to the Muslims and they have to submit
to the Muslims because the a passage I
mentioned earlier chapter 3 verse 110
the Muslims are the best of people on
earth and the passage goes on to say you
are the best of people enjoining what is
right and forbidding what is wrong so
the Muslims know what's right and wrong
and the non-muslims Do Not and so it's
the responsibility of the Muslims
to teach the non-muslims what's right
and wrong but this is not a classroom
setting or a situation of
uh uh student and teacher it's
a situation of Master and slave or the
one who submits and the one who is the
overlord can you say more about this
because it's very clear living here in
the Middle East that it is a rule or B
ruled mentality yeah please tell me tell
me more about that okay take for example
the Temple Mount and there two mosques
on the Temple Mount why are there two
mosques on the Temple Mount it's not
just a coin incidence they're two
mosques on the Temple Mount because it's
the Temple Mount because the idea was
when they were built in the 690s to
assert the the defeat of the Jews and
the Victory of Islam over
Judaism that is a a a universal practice
I wrote a book in 2018 the history of
jihad and in it I've got an extensive
history of the Jihad against India and
in India there are literally thousands
of Hindu temples that the Muslims
destroyed and then they built a mosque
on the site of the temple and not only
that but they took the idols the statues
of the Hindu gods and broke them into
pieces and strewed the pieces along the
pathway to the mosque so that every time
the Muslims went to pray they'd be
trampling on the Hindu gods yeah we see
them doing
yep excuse me no you see that doing with
the with the Israeli flag on a regular
basis there you go and see the idea is
to assert that we are the dominant
people these are the people who should
be submitting and we have victory over
them this is this is not
extremism or some uh strange eccentric
sect of Islam this is mainstream basic
fundamental Islam across all the sects
and schools of jurist prudence and it's
the same thing with Christianity one of
the foremost mosques in the world is a
Sophia in Istanbul which was the
foremost cathedral in the Christian
world for nearly a thousand years from
537 when it was built to 1453 when
Constantinople was conquered and the
building was immediately transformed
into a mosque in order to show the
superiority of Islam overr Christianity
and the Victory of Islam over
Christianity so it works in whatever
context this the same thing you know as
a matter of fact um I uh I myself became
notorious about 15 years ago now when
Pamela Geller and I in New York City led
a successful fight to defeat the idea of
building a 16 story Mega mosque at
Ground Zero on the site of one of the
buildings that was destroyed in the 9/11
attacks and everybody said oh this is
going to be a mosque of reconciliation
and peace and you're being bigoted and
hateful and racist and
the fact of the matter that was
completely ignored is that all over the
world there's not a single Mosque of
reconciliation and peace with
unbelievers that's just not a concept in
Islam there there are many very fine
people who are Muslims who are all about
reconciliation and peace but I'm talking
about Islamic theology here not about
individuals and there are literally
thousands of triumphal mosques that were
built either on the site of places of
worship of conquered people or in the
buildings that were appropriated from
conquered people that were made into
mosques in order to show the victory of
Islam and that ground zero Megam musque
would have been
another America not being a religious
entity it wasn't a grand church or
something that was destroyed America
being a secular state but being the
economic Powerhouse of the world you
destroy the World Trade Center the in
New York City the the symbol of American
economic power and then you put a mosque
there it's the same principle the same
impulse showing the victory of Islam
that's incredible I didn't even know of
that that's really powerful statement
you in certainly in Judaism there's
multiple interpretations of of Any Given
text is there anything like that
comparable in Islam or is
there are there agree are there
arguments is there General agreement you
go to this this
um this you know Imam for your one
opinion and another for I mean how does
that work well there is variance of
opinion and and particularly in the west
in the United States it's easy to find
Islamic scholars who say oh let's all
coexist and and and so on and that's
great but the fact is that literalism is
mainstream in Islam in a way that it has
is not now and never has been in either
Judaism or Christianity and the various
schools of jurist prudence in
Islam that are quite influential in the
Islamic world all interpret the passages
that I am discussing in generally the
way that I discuss there is no sect of
Islam that teaches that Muslims should
not wage war against unbelievers in
order to establish the global hegemony
of Islam that's a core Islamic Doctrine
it's almost completely obscured in the
west there's a great deal of deception
about it and a great deal of lying about
it it's but nonetheless if you read
material that is written by Muslims and
for Muslims it's spoken about quite
openly and this is not to say of course
that every Muslim believes these things
or does these things anym than any
average Jew or Christian is going to be
completely on board with everything
that's written in his or her scriptures
but the theology is there and thus it is
always there to be exploited by those
who wish to do
so so that's really so key the
literalism so so much hope for us here
in the region and really I think
everywhere is this idea of of seeing
Islam go through a reform seeing there
really be able to you know the idea yes
of the Abra of the Abraham Accords of of
this idea of being able
to make agreements and keep them what's
the what's the real of that is it that
Islam hasn't gone through its reform yet
will it do you have any realistic hope
for
that chapter 5:3 of the Quran says this
day I have perfected your religion for
you that's Allah speaking uh now if he
perfected the
religion then you're going to change it
you're only going to make it worse if
it's perfect now it does need fixing so
there have been reformers throughout
Islamic history in the book The History
of jihad I discuss quite a few of them
but the thing about the reformers in
Islam is they're not looking for some
new understanding of Islam that would be
bidah Innovation which is a very big sin
you don't innovate because the religion
is already perfect you just enact it as
it was handed down to you
and
so the
reformers what they are to a
man are people who are trying to
restore the initial
original vision of Islam at a time when
they contend that it has been corrupted
and the difficulty of that is that the
original vision of Islam going back to
the Quran and the Traditions about
Muhammad are quite violent and supress
IST and
degressive and
so take for example the Abraham Accords
that you mentioned those are real things
and as long as the Islamic Republic of
Iran remains a threat they will likely
remain
viable but they are pragmatic based they
are not based on Islam as a matter of
fact every one of the countries that
entered into those Accords is under
pressure from Islamic hardliners because
of entering into an agreement with the
Jews and if at any point the Islamic
Republic were to fall which is something
we can all hope
for the Abraham Accords will also fall
because if Iran is no longer a threat
then there will no be no there won't be
any more reason for them Islam is always
going to remain and eventually Islam
will destroy the Abraham Accords one way
or the other now I'm not a Muslim and
I'm not saying that Islam is going to
Prevail ultimately there are deep
divisions within the Islamic world and
there's a massive crisis of apostasy now
because in the in the Modern Age you
can't keep the truth about Islam out of
the Islamic World it used to be you know
you grew up in Riad or or or kabell and
you would never hear anything but what
the what what the imams and mulas taught
you but now you can go online and and
and read my website or read or watch
YouTube videos of critics of Islam and
see
that a lot of it doesn't make any sense
and is contradictory on its face and
people are reconsidering and are leaving
the thing so I don't mean to in other
words give no hope whatsoever but the
idea that there's going to be massive
reform in Islam is always going to meet
with the fact that the reformers will
have been and will be challenged by
people within the Islamic community as
being guilty of innovation and thus
being Heretics who deserve death rather
than reformers who have a new vision who
deserve respect Mahmud Muhammad Taha was
a reformer in Sudan in
1985 and he formulated a vision of Islam
that was based on the
idea in the Quran you know there are two
there two different kinds of passages
the there are meccan chapters and
medinan chapters because Muhammad is
supposed to have lived in Mecca for the
first 12 years of his career a prophet
and then moved to Medina and he got
revelations in both places the medinan
passages are generally considered to
take precedence over the meccan
ones because they just they follow later
and the idea is that uh what comes later
supersedes what comes earlier
unfortunately for the rest of the world
the most violent passages are in the
medinan part that comes later so M mm
Muhammad tah said why don't we flip this
and say the meccan passages take
precedence and formulate a Theology of
coexistence with the non-muslims and he
was hanged by the Sudanese government as
a heretic in
1985 this is not a 100 th not not a
thousand years ago not even not even a
100 years ago
1985 was within the lifetime of many of
us and so
uh this is the situation that reformers
face and a lot of people who who blly
put their hope in Islamic reform don't
really realize what the situation is for
reformers in the Islamic world or the
nature of Islamic
theology so you said that you think
people are leaving abandoning Islam more
more but the
the well the word on the street was
exactly the opposite I think it on on on
your website that you you referenced a
14-year-old girl who was planning a
stabbing attack just just this week I
believe what what is attracting young
people with their whole lives ahead to
commit I mean and in Europe I'm not
talking about down the road here it
seems from our point of view that people
are running to Islam that they're
running to any sort of coherence sort of
that feeling of being part of something
but but you're saying that you think
people are leaving i' I'd love to hear
which which part you see both things are
true at the same time uh there are a lot
of converts to Islam in the west I'm not
sure I don't have that story in front of
me right now I don't remember that girl
was a convert the 14-year-old she I
don't know she converted you're right I
don't know whether she was a convert but
she was a 14-y old girl who
good a good point she certainly got the
idea whether she was a convert or not
that it would be a holy act that would
be pleasing to Allah and would secure
her a place in Paradise if she killed
infidels now that comes from the Quran
the Quran
actually it it can it can cause people
great mental
anguish as all religions can uh but
chapter 21:4 47 I'm not saying that's
the only thing they do but but anyway
chapter 21:47 of the Quran says that
there are Grand scales and Allah will
put your good deeds on one scale and
your bad Deeds on another and if your
good deeds outweigh your bad Deeds to go
to paradise if your bad Deeds outweigh
your good deeds you go to hell okay so
very simple idea but how much does a
deed weigh how much do each of your
different Deeds weigh and how many of
each do you have
Nobody Knows the answers to those
questions and so it can drive you crazy
and you start thinking okay how many
Good Deeds do I have am I going to hell
am I out have my bad Deeds outweighed my
good nobody knows and so what can you do
well the Quran contains a guarantee of
paradise and that's chapter 9 verse 111
it says that paradise is guarantee to
Those Who Kill and are killed for a
la if Paradise is guaranteed to Those
Who Kill and are killed for Allah then
all you have to do is go and kill some
infidels and if you get killed in the
process then you have a place in
Paradise there is no doubt about it and
so excuse me this 14-year-old girl she
may have been thinking that
because secular people have a great deal
of trouble understanding religious ideas
secular people of whatever
tradition but you have to we have to put
this into the context of thinking this
is absolutely real this is not a
metaphor this is not literature this is
not anything but the absolute words of
the creator of the
universe and so he's going to torture
you
forever if you have been bad Beyond his
standards and that's very real in the
Quran the Tes of hell are very lavishly
described he's going to pour molten lead
down your throat he's going to burn your
body up and then when your body is gone
he's going to give you a new one so he
can burn that one
too there are all kinds of terrible
things that are going to happen to you
and they're never going to stop
happening all you have to do to be free
of that and never to worry about that
again is kill these these terrible
people people over here the most vile of
created beings which is what the Quran
in chapter 98:6 calls the unbelievers
among the people of the book who are
Jews and
Christians all you have to do is kill
them and if they kill you so much the
better then you're
guaranteed so there's been this
idea that there's and I and I hear what
you're saying and pardon me while I
adust the language but this idea that
there's a
islamism radical Islam that that there's
a a some percentage of of those who
adhere to the more Savage and barbaric
parts that you've you've described but
you're saying that this is actually
really part and parcel to the entire
framework in the entire religious so why
are there so this explains number one
why so much of the acts of Terror that
we see by the vast vast majority are
people of is our people of uh Muslims
but there's still a percentage that act
on this so what are we looking at
percentage wise realistically there's
two million Israeli Arabs that live here
and live here quite happily um having
embraced some other version at least
embrac progress uh and um a good
economic life if nothing
else but what would you say about that
what what sort of percentage out of if
we're talking about two billion
Muslims percentages are are are very
tough in this in this regard and I'll
explain why you mentioned at the
beginning of the question the idea that
this was a an extremist View and that
that a view that was held by only a
minority of Muslims in a certain sense
that's right but in a certain sense it's
not right this is
a mainstream view in Islamic
Theology and is taught by all the major
schools of jurist prudence all the
centers of Islamic learning Alazar and
Cairo all the rest of them the the deab
bondes in India they are going to teach
the kind of Islam that I'm talking about
but human nature is everywhere the same
and there are a lot of people among
those 1.8 billion or however many
Muslims you want to say there are a lot
of people who will hear all this and Nod
and go home and think okay what's for
dinner and and what's on TV or whatever
and they're never going to kill any
infidels they're really not all that
interested in the whole thing just as
there are Jews and Christians and Hindus
and Buddhists who will call you they'll
call themselves that if you ask them but
they're really not
interested and for that we can all be
grateful but
they don't have a theological leg to
stand on within Islam it's not as if the
peaceful Muslims who live in Israel and
elsewhere have an understand are are
from the the the X sect that teaches
peace and love and butterflies and
Harmony there is no such
sect they don't have a different view of
Islam they just don't pay attention
they think you know that's something for
other people to do which is actually a
concept in Islam that uh Jihad is
actually Faya which is an obligation
that is incumbent upon the community as
a whole and if it's discharged by a part
of the community then the rest of the
community is exempt from
it however if a Muslim land is
considered to have been attack then
Jihad becomes far which is incumbent
upon every individual Muslim and of
course that is the contention of mmud
abas and all the Palestinian leaders
that an Islamic land has been attacked
this mythical land of Palestine that was
supposedly an Arab Muslim land and
consequently every Muslim has this
obligation to wage Jihad but still
you're going to have plenty of people
who just are not going to play now the
problem is is that they are always
vulnerable to recruitment from the
hardliners because the hardliners can
take Quran chapter and verse and the
example of Muhammad and the teachings of
Islamic law and say look you're not
doing what you're supposed to be doing
you're headed for hell and there have
always been recruits and probably always
will be who are made on that
basis uh the percentages thus are very
difficult to say because you have all
these Muslims
countless millions of them who are never
going to wage Jihad because they don't
have the courage they don't have the
will they prefer to be interested in
other things they're not that religious
whatever but that could change you know
they go through a life crisis and they
think I need to get closer to God and
then suddenly they're blowing themselves
up we've seen that in the stories of
terrorist after
terrorist you know even the 9/11
hijackers they say they they were not
they weren't Muslims they were drinking
in a strip club the night before well
you know why they were drinking in a
strip club the night before BEC not
because they weren't Muslims but
because they knew they were going to be
doing this supreme Act of
jihad somebody came up to Muhammad once
according to an Islamic tradition and
asked him can you give me a deed that is
greater than
Jihad and Muhammad said I do not know of
such a deed so jihad's the greatest
thing a Muslim can do these guys knew
they were going to do this tremendous
active Jihad the next day and kill all
these
infidels so they kind of had a free pass
that night they could sin however they
wanted because they knew that it would
all be outweighed by their great Act of
jihad the next day so it doesn't mean
they were not Muslims they were very
Pious but that's just how Islam
works and so you ask me for a percentage
the problem is that a lot of these
Muslims who they might be going to bars
and drinking or living with their
girlfriends or doing any number of
things that are strictly speaking not
Islamic but they really do believe in
all this and maybe one day it will kick
in maybe it
won't and so are they extremists are
they jihadis well not really no they're
just the guy that runs the Falafel shop
or whatever but maybe that will change
one day maybe it
won't you never
know really fascinating to me to speak
about this idea that's one of these
hidden in plain sight type of things of
Islamic
Conquering the the idea of Islam
conquering these lands and and speaking
specifically about Israel speaking of
what we see happening throughout the
region and what that means for this I'd
really like to hear your opinion on the
open borders in the west why yeah that's
just crazy and suicidal right uh when it
comes to Concepts being hidden in plain
sight I did want to mention that's one
of the reasons why the whole October 7th
thing was called alaka flood because
they're so enraged at at Jews going onto
the Temple Mount even if they're not
allowed to pray and they're only there
for a few hours every day where the
Muslims can come and and pray as they
please it's an insult
to the whole idea of the Temple mount
for Muslims which is the Victory and
supremacy of
Islam but nobody seems to understand
that and so it's never it's never
discussed in those terms anyway I'm
sorry I just want to interject that for
100 years talking about hajin yeah Al
husseini for 100 years what's been so
fantastically jaw-dropping every single
day when you open your computer is that
the exist exact same incitement has been
working they have been saying oh no the
Jews are coming for for for the alxa
mosque for 100 years and inciting people
instantly overnight certainly there's
other lials that go back even further
than that but it's the exact same
arguments about Israel it's the exact
same arguments from the Muslim world and
it was also even before that from from
Crusades and Christianity before that I
just had to say 100 Years of
they know that's what's going to really
get people fired up because that strikes
at the heart of the whole idea of Islam
which is submission and the unbelievers
are not
submitting they're daring to challenge
our hegemony so they have to be put down
anyway the open border it's Madness
there have been hundreds of people on
the terror watch list apprehended over
the last year there was a trickle of
people on the terror watch list who were
apprehended at the border before that
and it skyrocketed when the Border got
out of control and uh that's just the
people that were apprehended we have to
understand that for everyone that's
caught there are a lot unknown unknown
numbers who got through and where are
they we don't know what are they going
to do we don't know but I think that it
it's quite abundantly clear that it's
not just a question of if there will be
an attack but when and the the the
people are in place here
now why do you think that we have
implemented such absurd policy despite
all evidence these are not stupid people
I mean maybe some of them but let's be
honest not all of the all of the
politics in here you know in the US and
in the EU are all beyond their
comprehension what they're letting in
why yeah I don't think uh I don't think
they're stupid at all I think they're
evil and what they are
they're marxists they're socialist
internationalists and they have taken
over the Democrat Party and they have
normalized a kind of soft and stealth
Marxism and they are destroying the
United States of America as a nation
state and they want to do that because
they're internationalists and they want
to create an international socialist
Mega State and the international
socialist Mega state is against the very
idea of something like the United States
of America as the world's foremost
nation state today and so if you destroy
the world's foremost nation state the
rest of them are going to be easier and
will fall into line so
they are opening the Border letting in
an Untold unknowable number of criminals
and terrorists the idea is to terrorize
the native population into
submission and also
to dilute the native population so that
it doesn't have the voting power it used
to have so that it can be more easily
brought into
submission and then once you have
this massive mess that you've created
with all this chaos and unrest then you
have a very easy justification for
clamping down and installing an
authoritarian regime that is
internationalist and socialist in
character and then we'll Unite with
other authoritarian regimes elsewhere
and they also hate Israel of course
because Israel is a state built on
particularity the left is
collectivists collectivists hate
particularity think about Mouse China
and everybody wore those little uniforms
why did everybody wear the same clothes
because that was Equity that's what
kamla Harris and and all the rest of
them are promising us
Equity well what's equity if your
clothes are nicer than mine see we don't
have Equity so we wear the same clothes
then we have equity and you make exactly
the same money as I do Equity no matter
what no matter how smart you are how
industrious you are and how lazy I am
and stupid I am we still make the same
money that's equity and so you erase all
distinctions between people that's
Equity then nobody can say that
anybody's better than anybody else and
finally we have
Justice it's sort of a perversion of
actual justice but that's the vision and
so here's Israel that is based on the
idea of being a Jewish
State Arabs can live there they have
lived there they have completely equal
rights the apartheid business is a lot
of hoie but it's a Jewish
state so it has to be destroyed because
we have to erase all distinction between
people because they get in the way of
equity and
collectivism so the left is in charge in
the United States they're busy
destroying the United States and
installing Equity collectivism socialism
internationalism and Israel has to go as
well and of course today we have the
technology to be able to to implement
exactly that we have the ability to what
was only the dream of of Hitler and Ma
and and all of these people back you
know we we can ensure that absolute
enforced equality or you know
authoritarian Vision so so translate
that thought into what we see out of the
Biden Administration what we see from
this appeasement the lack of deterrence
you're say is that also sort of the
taking down of borders type of thing
it's not naive and thinking we're gonna
you know start roing roasting
marshmallows with the Ayatollah anytime
soon like really you know they don't
really believe that they they know I
don't think it's naive T at all I think
that they're on the side of Hamas they
want Israel to lose this
war and it seems to me
unmistakable what happened right after
October 7th it actually took a little
while but finally Biden made it over to
Israel and he stands there with
Netanyahu and professes his undying
support and by the way he says I'm
giving a hundred million doar to Gaza
for humanitarian Aid and if that money
goes to Hamas boy am I gonna be mad well
who who who Who's G to keep it out of
the hands of Hamas who is he trying to
kid there's no entity in Gaza at that
time or now that could possibly stand up
to Hamas if the United States of America
knocked on somebody's door and the you
know some UN agency or some humanitarian
Aid group or who knows what in Gaza and
handed them the 10100
million and left and said don't give it
to Hamas what happens next Hamas knocks
on the door next they have all the guns
what's where's the 100 million going to
go now does Biden not know that Biden
might not know that because Biden ain't
there but the people who run Biden they
know that full well so the first thing
the United States did after all the
professions of undying support was
support Hamas give money to
Hamas even
worse then there was the 10 billion
dollar of sanctions relief the sanctions
waver that the Biden Administration
approved for
iran1 billion for Iran who's financing
Hamas Iran who's financing Iran Biden so
the United States of America is funding
the the war against
Israel and so then they they they say
we're on Israel's side okay
so Israel take goes into Gaza and fights
in Gaza and and O destroys Hamas almost
everywhere and then there are four
intact Hamas battalions in Rafa and
that's the the last
thing and then it becomes the worst
thing in the world and the Israelis
can't go into Rafa no no no you must not
go into Rafa whatever you do and I think
oh come on what's what's what's in Rafa
it makes me wonder because these Biden
people they are evil and they are on the
side of Hamas obviously they want to
preserve Hamas they clearly want Israel
to fail and Hamas to live but what else
are they afraid the Israelis are going
to find I wouldn't be in the least
surprised I don't know I don't have any
inside information but I wouldn't be in
the least surprised given the people who
were in The Biden Administration and the
nature of the Biden Administration if
the Israelis were to discover in Rafa
that the Biden administration had been
actively financing
Hamas and aiding it maybe even sending
it weapons who knows I wouldn't be in
the least surpris and that's why they're
so nervous about Israel in Rafa
well Israel has always had to lose
Israel's not allowed to win any of its
of its Wars it's interesting to hear
your perspective I mean either way they
are financing it quite directly everyone
knows there's I'm wrong about Rafa
there's no doubt the Biden
Administration is financing the Hamas
war effort that is beyond dispute 10
billion to come
on and everybody knows that what's such
a mistake as you know language has lost
its meaning is is first of all people
don't even refer to it as a war between
Israel and Kamas it's Israel and Gaza
right it's Israel's attack on Gaza but
really it's Israel and Iran it's just
all this semantics which seems to help
people you know enjoy their delusions
that much longer and I appreciated the
idea of of when you talk about Israel
being this distinction and and it goes
back to this idea that what keeps you
from Daddy government is God you know is
is family it's any of these types of
thing that we see that it has been you
know actively degraded or any of those
things that sent you to something that's
bigger greater than you um and and and
government is waiting to be its
replacement so there you go and so
that's why Israel has to be
destroyed and the United States with the
character that it once had as the
world's policeman so-called or as the
the The Shining City on the hill as
Ronald Reagan said and as a place where
Jews had a situation of Freedom relief
from persecution that was unprecedented
in human history and there was there was
peace and coexistence and friendly
relations with the Christian majority
and all that is being
destroyed well what's going to replace
it an authoritarian government and so
you you destroy God you put the
government in place it's exactly what
you were
saying I felt like if if the upheaval if
the chaos that is being you know
welcomed in actually you know resols
Border Police snipping away uh fence in
order to let people in
um I believe that it's this idea if you
want to talk in sort of biblical terms
right of adom or Ishmael this I think
that that Adam Rome if you will can't
imagine Ishmael getting the better of it
and so it feels like I can let you in
and sort of do this sort of control
demolition but I actually think that's
one of this tremendous fallacies is this
idea that they think they'll be able to
stop it once it's once it's in oh yeah
yeah well you know you look at the
leftist alliance with Islam it's not
going to end well for them even if they
uh succeed in achieving all their goals
then they're going to turn on each other
and I don't think the left will win
Islam is an older Force it's it's more
deeply rooted in among the people you
look for example at the Islamic Republic
of Iran uh when Ki overthrew the Sha the
Tuda party the leftists in Iran they
were all for it and they were Coman
allies and they thought he will reward
us with a place in his government and he
threw them in
prison and uh these people think they
can ride the tiger now it's the same
thing something that I I want to clarify
this idea of again of the Arab
conquering so the truth is though but
this land of
Israel so the irony it's one of these
fantastic memes that go around you know
I we give you this land of milk and
honey and and you know fruits the size
of basketballs and we say what's the
catch and they say wait till you meet
your neighbors um so so so here we are
placed in this land but it was never a
it was never an a country it was never
there was no cohesive Arab presence or
or or leadership um but what does that
mean that means anything that they I
want to understand about Israel
specifically but does this mean anywhere
that they conquer that they
become the you know more than once
they're the majority that they must
conquer that means that Germany is now
Islamic
land Germany is just about yeah it's
it's it's it never was historically and
so it's a different situation Spain that
I mentioned earlier Spain was Islamic
land you had the Alanda Lucia the
caliphate there the Fatimid
caliphate that was an Islamic entity and
so just as Islamic hardliners would say
that isra belongs by right to Islam so
they would also say that Spain
does see in classic Islam historical
it's not what they conquer now as they
as they make their moves well there's
both oh okay see in classic Islamic
theology the world is divided into two
parts the daral Islam the house of Islam
and the Dar Al harb the house of war and
so Germany is part of the House of War
it is part of the responsibility of
Muslims to always wage war against the
house of war in order to diminish it and
enlarge the house of
Islam but like I like brv said what we
have we hold and so any land that was
part of the House of Islam at any time
is always part of the House of Islam and
it becomes part of the responsibility of
the Muslims to drive them out where they
drove you out according to the Quran
chapter 2 verse 191 and consequently to
fight to restore that land to the house
of Islam a land can't just go from the
house of Islam to the house of war and
be left alone that's that's not possible
at least according to the theology so
Israel has to go Spain has to be
islamized but also the rest of Europe
that was never Islamic has to be
incorporated into the house of Islam as
well so it's very clear they say it out
loud seen countless countless videos
that's what the thing you don't have one
off the same video you see circulate
again you see very clearly there's a
desire to create a world caulifa so are
we essentially would you agree that we
are sort of Pawns in a massive religious
War to see a caulif fat uh established
to as well as a a a war between Sunni
and Shiite um a win out of that is are
we just part and parcel to this their
their great battle yes the the in the
first place it's very important to
understand that Khalifa means successor
and the traditional understanding is
that he's the successor of the the
caleff is the successor of Muhammad as
the political military and spiritual
leader of the Muslims and the kaith by
right is the only Authority on Earth
that the Muslims ow Allegiance to not to
some president or Nation or King but
only to the worldwide umah the Islamic
community now the last caliphate was the
Ottoman
Empire and it fell at the end of World
War
I there was a figurehead cff that was
ended on March 3rd
1924 by the secular Turkish government
so March 3rd 192 before according to all
the Jihad groups in the world including
Hamas and all the rest of them was the
beginning of all their troubles because
before that the um was United it wasn't
really but this is this is the story The
umah has been disunited ever since and
under the control of the West when the
West should be submitting to the Muslims
not the other way around but the West
came in and made
colonies excuse me and established
states that were its it's its proxies or
its colonies and Israel is one of those
according to this View and so the great
goal of the Jihad groups worldwide is
to destroy all these states and reunite
the Islamic world as one umah and
restore the C alate as the with the kff
as the successor of Muhammad being the
sole legitimate ruler this is part of
standard Islamic theology now you
mention the Sunni Shiite split this is
Sunni Islamic theology in Shiite Islamic
theology the leader of the Muslim
Community has to be a member of
Muhammad's household that is a a Rel a
blood relative somehow of Muhammad now
that was extinguished in
874 when the last of the imams of the
Shiites was murdered by the sunnis and
the uh the Shiites believe that that boy
who was 5 years old at the time he was
killed because this was a hereditary
monarchy in the Shiites since it has to
be a blood relative of Muhammad it was a
line that was passed down and the last
one was this 5-year-old boy who was
murdered he is in
occultation he is hiding but he is alive
and he will return at a time when the
Muslims are more persecuted than they
ever were in before in history and then
he will conquer and islamize the world
in conjunction with Jesus the Muslim
Prophet who will come back and break the
cross and Destroy Christianity and
establish Islamic emany all over the
world now this is a Shiite idea this is
it at variance with the sunnis who they
believe in the Jesus part but they don't
believe in the 12th Imam part and so
there is likely to be conflict between
the two of them over this forever but uh
they both have these apocalyptic visions
of the end of the world where uh the you
the fullness of Islamic emony over the
world will be established and this also
is a threat to Jews because Muhammad in
a in a very important statement in
Islamic tradition says that the end the
last day will not
come that this great consummation of all
things and the total victory of Islam
will not come until Muslims kill Jews
and the Jews will hide behind trees and
the trees will cry out oh Muslim there
is a Jew hiding behind me come and kill
him except for the garod tree which is
the tree of the Jews and they're
actually Islamic clerics today who say
you see the Israelis they're planting
garod trees all over
Israel because they're waiting for the
end as if the Israelis believe this and
the idea though is it's not just an
apocalyptic Vision remember it says the
last hour will not come until Muslims
kill Jews so if Muslims want to bring
about the total victory of
Islam and the final islamization of the
world they kill Jews to do
it so Christians get it past because
they can convert and Jesus comes back
but Moses doesn't come back no Jesus is
GNA come back it's a very curious thing
in Islamic theology ever heard this yeah
Muhammad is is the last and greatest
Prophet but it's Jesus who comes back at
the end of the world uh and there are a
lot of reasons for that that we can get
into but they're a bit tangential for
our discussion today but the the it's
not that Christians get a pass because
this is not Jesus of Christianity this
is Jesus
the Muslim Prophet Jesus and what he
will do when he comes back is he will
break the cross kill the pig and abolish
the gizia now those three things have to
do with Christianity break the cross is
because the Quran says in chapter 4
verse 157 that the the the Jews say we
killed the Messiah Jesus the son of
Mary but this is a saying among them
they do not know for certain they did
not kill or crucify him but it appeared
so to them so in other words the Jews
are running around this is in the Quran
the Jews are running around boasting
that they killed Jesus but they did not
actually do so they did not crucify him
he did not die on a cross at all so the
Christians when they have their crosses
that is an insult to Allah because Allah
would not allow one of his prophets to
suffer such a
humiliation and so Jesus when he comes
back is going to break all the crosses
which means destroy
Christianity kill the pig because the
Christians say this is the Messiah who
freed us and we don't have to obey the
laws that were in place previously so
they don't have food laws
so the Muslims have the food laws
the pork is going to all be killed
because the the all this is over now and
this false religion of Christianity is
going to be destroyed and abolish the
gizia the gizia is the tax specified in
chapter 9 ver 29 of the Quran that the
uh people of the book that is the Jews
and the Christians must pay to the
Muslims as a sign of their submission
and historically in the Islamic Empires
the Jews and Christians always paid this
tax that the Muslims don't have to pay
they were actually the economic base for
the great Islamic Empires when the
Jewish and Christian Community were
impoverished by having to pay this tax
over the centuries then those Empires
went into decline that's why the Ottoman
Empire went into Decline and ultimately
fell because it stopped conquering new
lands and it bled dry the Jews and
Christians in the lands it had conquered
didn't have any more economic base but
anyway he'll AB Jesus when he comes back
will abolish the gizia that is that
intermediate state that the Jews and
Christians can be in
now but not at the end of the world the
idea is you have to either convert to
Islam or submit and pay the
gizia or be killed Jesus when he comes
back he's going to abolish the Giza
which means you have to either convert
or be killed so then all the Christians
will either convert to Islam or be
killed the Jews will be killed except
the ones that are behind the garod trees
and the whole world will be
Islamic it's absolutely fascinating a
bit of a turn and something that
obviously troubles me
deeply and everyone
who um was in Israel certainly we live
what I you know affectionately call a
kind of Frogger Frogger existence right
you go out to the store you get on the
road you just don't get any guarantees
um none of us do you get that a lesson
up close so there's certainly been I I
know you know very well the fogal case
there have
been isolated as it were incidences
throughout history um of horrifically
brutal attacks so October 7th made it
impossible to see those as isolated
incidents or is anything except exactly
what it was um and what I want to speak
about
is what's so unusual about that is this
the
barbarity but the
jubilance the
exhilaration with which it it happens
because we talked about our shared
Humanity you know and
certainly As Americans as as people of
democra democratic countries we're
mostly Live and Let Live maybe you annoy
me a little more you little less but but
you know we kind of want to get on with
it um can you explain that to me that
level of you know I I said this recently
you John Spencer no you know has has has
taken many people into battle many
soldiers into battle no one's
jubilant no one goes in without fear
without an ounce of fear um videotaping
and calling home to Dad so
your thoughts on that how could they do
that I guess I'm curious about here we
are all humans and how can I guess I
want to understand
more the the personalness of it the the
the savagery the the absolute horrific
tearing apart the taking home pieces of
bodies as a souvenir the jubilance of of
making that happen that's a religious
fervor I don't know could we compare
that that to the Crusades I don't know
oh it's much worse far worse in in in in
see you talk about our shared
humanity and that's that's a Jewish idea
that's a Christian idea but it's not an
Islamic
idea I've mentioned these passages
before but let me emphasize them chapter
3 ver 110 of the Quran you were the best
of people on the Earth in joining what
is right and forbidding what is wrong
the
corollary 98:6 of the Quran the
unbelievers among the people of the book
are the most vile of created
beings chapter 8 verse 55 of the Quran
the unbelievers are like
animals chapter 7 verse 179 they're like
cattle no they're
worse because the cattle are
ignorant
so you've got the best of people on
earth you've got the most vile of
created beings who were
animalistic who were like
animals so there's no no passage in the
Quran that says hey you know we're all
children of Abraham here or we're all
children of Adam for that matter uh Adam
was another Muslim prophet and they all
taught Islam and then there're these
animalistic Renegades who Twisted the
teachings of Islam to create these fake
religions they deserve no respect
they deserve no human consideration and
to drive the point Home chapter 48: 29
of the Quran
Muhammad is the Apostle of Allah those
who follow him are ruthless to
unbelievers merciful to one
another now this is the word of Allah
this is not some this is not even
Muhammad speaking this
is excuse me the creator of the stars
and the galaxies speaking this is the
the f ER of everything on in that is
imaginable speaking and so this is not
our common Humanity or our shared uh
human nature there's no idea of that
these people
are evil they are enemies of
Allah they are
animals and so what do you do you kill
them and you
rejoice because not only that there's a
very very telling
passage chapter 9 verse1 14- 15 of the
Quran fight them and Allah will punish
them by your
hands and
soothe the bosoms of the
Believers so what do you get from this
passage you have to fight the
unbelievers and in so far as you do so
Allah is going to be executing his
Divine wrath through you so you know
vengeance is mine says the Lord I will
repay there's no concept of that in
Islam in Islam fight them and Allah will
punish them by your hands so when they
came out of Gaza on October 7th and
murdered all the
Israelis they were the wrath of Allah
they were executing the wrath of Allah
on the most vile of created
beings so who wouldn't rejoice when
you're doing such a holy
act and it will soothe the bosoms of the
Believers so if you're troubled if you
are depressed about your life
situation but you go and you kill an
unbeliever then you can feel
satisfaction in your heart because
you're pleasing
Allah and so Rejoice this is the time to
be
happy so that goes in line sir certainly
with the the mass rape the the
humiliation that's that that that I can
conceptualize there's more for the mass
rape as well but yes the idea is that
the unbelievers need to be humiliated
and shown that they must submit
definitely but also chapter 4:3 of the
Quran says that you can marry up to four
women and the captives of the right hand
now who are the captives of the right
hand chapter 4: 24 gives you very
precise instructions as to who you may
have sexual relations with and who you
may not and so it says you're forbidden
to you are your mother and your sister
etc etc but not the captives of the
right hand and chapter 33: 50 says they
are The Spoils of War Chapter 23 verse
1-6 says that the righteous man guards
his private part except with his wife
wives and the captives of the right hand
and so this is one of the things that's
specified in the Quran that it is
permissible to take women who are
non-muslims as spoilers of war and to
rape them to use them sexually they are
permitted to you and in doing so you are
pleasing Allah because you are as you
noted humiliating them and showing them
that they are the most vile of created
beings and that you were the best of
people
so
GoPro the most horrific crimes against
humanity your opinion on on on on why to
publicize it to the world because this
is from an Islamic standpoint These Are
Holy sacred acts these are not heinous
crimes these are acts of service to
Allah as I have explained so you take
for example an analogy to the
rapes in England for decades now there
have been Pakistani rape gangs operating
in England with
impunity and the British authorities
have been cravenly
cowardly afraid to apprehend them for
fear of being called racist and
islamophobic because they were all
Pakistani men and Muslims a lot of
people have noted that they were
pakistanis as if there was something
intrinsic about their being Pakistani
but that actually is just a consequence
of the fact that it's a large number of
pakistanis immigrating to England the
real situation was that they were
Muslims and they were considering these
girls to be the captives of the right
hand now the point I'm trying to make
here is this these people didn't feel
ashamed of this you look at the con the
composition of the rape gangs and a lot
of times it's and son or a bunch of
brothers and their
cousins and they would all get the
family men to join in and nobody thought
oh this is a shameful thing to do this
is terrible because in Islam this is
what you do to The Spoils of War the
captives of the right hand and so you
are pleasing Allah when you fulfill his
commands and so nobody thought twice
about it and they said you know hey
Uncle ammed come on and join in
it's a party and it's something that
pleases a
laot something that I find
confusing I can understand the GoPro of
sort of you know letting that smell of
blood flood the Islamic world but that
it's the little children that I I can't
wrap my head around because say I see a
puppy or a calf say I think you know I'm
think of these people as animals there's
a very Human Experience of of reacting
to the vulnerable and the vulnerable are
targeted I can't wrap my head around it
if you have Divine RIT telling you these
people are not vulnerable these people
are the enemies of Allah these people
are the most intense and hostility
toward the best of people these people
are vile they are animals then this is
all priming you to try to override your
natural tendency to feel compassion for
the
vulnerable it's incredible um why you
see mothers you know uh all over in in
in Judea and Samaria as well as in Gaza
and they all they say you know my son
Muhammad he murdered six Jews and he was
martyred and I'm so happy he's in
Paradise with Allah overriding the
natural maternal
Instinct and saying I'm glad my son is
dead but this is because she is doing as
was instructed as she's been has been
drilled into her from from from birth
that this is what what is great in Islam
you know there's a saying that is very
common among Jihad terrorists and it is
we love death more than you love life I
see jihadis repeat this all the time
Palestinians as well as others all
around the world the Boston Marathon
bombers said it and it's all over the
place and it comes from chapter 62
verse6 of the Quran which is actually
directed to the Jews it says the Jews
say that we are God's chosen and his
beloved let them show they love death if
they're telling the truth because see if
you love if you if you're really the
chosen of the then you'll want to be
with Allah and not be on earth and so
you'll love
death W so that is the explanation why
we basically face a death cult that's
entirely clear you can only be so you
can only be close to Allah then once
you're dead so you have
to abide by Islam in order to actually
even get there yeah point also there's
the other thing I neglected to mention
and that is being horny that you have
young boys and you have a culture where
of course there's strict separation of
the Sexes so you have young boys and
they hear they're going to go to
paradise and what's in Paradise but the
virgins of paradise they're real it's
not it's you know know a lot of people
in the west they think this must be a
gag this is this is crazy but it's in
the Quran that there are these beautiful
women who are going to attend the
blessed in
Paradise nothing is said about what
Paradise is like for the women says the
women will go to paradise if they're
righteous but it doesn't say what it's
like but for men they get these girls
and they're are couches and you recline
on the couches and you enjoy Sumptuous
food and there's rivers of wine flowing
through and you have these
virgins and so a lot of these young boys
growing up in this culture where they
can't even get close to a
female there was actually a kid I
remember this some years ago who was
stopped at an Israeli checkpoint and
they sent out one of those machines you
know that disarm somebody wearing a bomb
vest it's a very sophisticated machine
that the IDF has and he's standing there
stripp to his shorts because he's uh
being the bomb vest is being deactivated
and surrounded at a great Distance by
soldiers and everything at this
checkpoint and he calls out how am I
going to get to Paradise now and get the
virgins and he's taking this with utmost
seriousness and so that's another thing
but also we have to understand that if
sex is the highest good that the blessed
in Paradise enjoy then it also lends an
aspect to it on Earth that the best way
to humiliate and destroy your enemy is
to destroy them sexually so you rape
them it brings me back full
circle to the idea that you said that
you there's no in between you're either
a you're either a sinner or you're a
good Muslim this is an idea that has
frustrated me so much in what I see
certainly by the Islamic Republic and
that the lack of accountability zero
accountability there is only you are the
Infidel the Jew the EV the women you
know every single entity in the world is
a problem and a pitfall for for for the
good Muslim but there is zero lack of
self-reflection or
accountability just want to I mean that
just seems to be
this rudimentary part that's missing
from the religion there's I don't where
is the self-reflection where is there
any sense
of of progress of
betterment there there is no progress or
betterment but there is self-reflection
and accountability it's just not what
you would expect it's all based on
divine
revelation so for example if you want a
spot an Islamic hardliner look at the
Cuffs of his trousers and if they are
very high then you know you're dealing
with somebody who's dangerous why
because there is a tradition in which
Muhammad says that he who lets the Hem
of His Garment Trail on the ground it is
trailing in
Hellfire why I don't know that's a
that's just one of those nutty things of
which there are many in Islamic
tradition
but that's why you will see these
salopes and they have these Michaels
pants with the with the the the Cuffs up
at the ankles
and this is accountability you know they
are taking account of what Muhammad said
and acting accordingly the problem is
when you see a guy like that you know
that he takes all of it very seriously
and that means he takes Jihad very
seriously as well and so watch what you
do and say around him and watch what he
does but there is a great sense of
accountability in the sense of yes I
could end up in Hellfire if I don't
scrupulously observe all the tenets of
the
religion but that doesn't extend to some
idea of accountability to humanity as a
force or as an entity at all there is
only the
um if
you were able to help make the decisions
how to keep
Israel safe and secure what would be
your recommendation Israel has to be
strong has to be much stronger than the
Jihad force in the first place because
actually Islamic law stipulates you
should not wage Jihad if you have no
chance of winning and that's why you
know people say this Jihad that we're
seeing in the world today it's a new
thing it's not in Islam really because
who's you know in the
1950s or 60s we didn't see people
blowing themselves up or take uh flying
planes into buildings yeah that's
true but that was because the West was
so much stronger then and is weak now
and so they think they can win that's
actually one of the foremost points that
Osama Bin Laden makes in his Declaration
of jihad against America that it's
really not as strong as it seems and
Allah La will grant Victory to the
righteous because as I noted way way
back there's a onetoone equation between
righteousness and victory on this Earth
anyway Israel if it's so strong that it
doesn't look as if there's any Prospect
of Victory then they should not fight
According to Islamic theology Israel
needs to pay attention to Islamic
theology Muhammad said war is
deceit and allowed for lying in Wartime
that's one of the only conditions one of
the handful of conditions in which lying
is allowed and so Hamas on October oer
8th there was a Hamas official on
Russian television boasting about how
they had told the Israelis that for two
years as they plotted the October 7th
attack they told the Israelis they were
more interested in governing Gaza than
in waging Jihad and the Israelis
believed them and left the Border
vulnerable why did they believe them
they should always they should put War
as deceit on the wall of every office in
the IDF headquarters
and study what that means and study what
Islamic treaty making is that the Treaty
of hudia is the foundation for all
Islamic treaty making and it only allows
for treaties with non-muslims on the
basis of the Islamic side is losing and
needs to buy time to fight again more
effectively so when Hamas says hey we
want a truce Hamas is telling you we're
losing and we need time to gather
strength now of course Biden is
interfering now because he's the biggest
Hamas
booster but there have been so many
times over the years that I've seen
Hamas asks for a truce and the Israelis
say yeah
okay no that's when they should have
pressed all the
harder and there's so many things in
Islam that if they understood Islam they
would not behave the way they do another
thing is the very concept of the
Palestinians the Palestinians do not
exist they were invented in
1964 before that there were no
Palestinians you look at 1947 and 48 and
all the UN deliberations over the
founding of Israel and the partition
nobody mentions Palestinians they didn't
exist they were the local Arabs they are
not different culturally linguistically
ethnically or cultur or or religiously
from the Arabs of Syria Lebanon and
Jordan monin Bean was pressured by Jimmy
Carter and Anar Sadat to accept at the
Camp David Accords the existence of the
Palestinians as a distinct people and
now it's been taken for granted the
Israeli government needs to roll that
back and say there are no Palestinians
we're dealing with Arabs and pressure
the syrians and the Lebanese and the
jordanians to end their hypocrisy and
allow citizenship for those people
because they're the
same in those neighboring countries and
then if if if see if this had been a
same situation without Islamic theology
then when the Arab higher committee told
the Arabs to leave Israel in
1948 they would have been allowed
citizenship in Syria Lebanon and Jordan
and there never would have been a
problem but the syrians lebanes and
jordanians jordanians did actually for a
while but the if if the neighboring
countries had allowed the Palestinian
Arabs
citizenship there never would have been
a problem they they did not because they
wanted to use them to destroy Israel the
KGB and Yasser Arafat invented the
Palestinians in 1964 as a rhetorical
trick and it's the biggest propaganda
deceit in the history of the world and
the most successful one absolutely the
the idea was see in the 1960s everybody
loved Israel because Israel was the
underdog facing 22 Arab states that
hated it that were massively larger than
it and he kept beating
them and people like that kind of story
The David versus Goliath the Plucky
Underdog winning against rapacious and
evil huge
enemies so the KGB they were masters of
propaganda they invented the
Palestinians and even smaller people
facing the mighty
IDF and they have put that lie over all
the world Israel needs to repudiate it
and stop taking for granted that the
Palestinians even exist as such or
deserve a state as a distinct ethnicity
and nationality when they aren't and
they're 22 Arab states why do we have to
have a 23rd and then they're going to
want a 24th and what's left of
Israel it it because of the Jihad
imperative that nobody wants to
acknowledge right and you know years ago
I was stting to Barry ruin and I saidou
know nobody seems interested in talking
about Islam in Israel he said that's
because they all know it that's because
they're all aware of what they're
dealing with and I thought actually it's
just the opposite I think Israel has no
idea about what Islam teaches or why
this situation keeps on being so
intractable and the key is all in Islam
and they don't want to face it they have
to face
it I think that that's um completely
true both both both the fact that well
the very existence of this palestin and
first of all there was quite a few
refugees in around 1945 people will
remember quite a few Jewish German um so
there's nothing special they're the only
people in the entire world who get 80
years of refugee status um and it passed
down from the children children's
children and I mean that's ridiculous
you know my grandparents were exiled
from the Ottoman Empire so if I were
Palestinian I'd be a refugee even though
I was born in the United States and my
parents were born of the United States
it's ridiculous but the grandchildren of
people who were in the area that is now
Israel and have never been there and
were born in Michigan or wherever
they're Palestinian refugees according
to the UN it's an absurd situation that
is just yet another weapon to use
against Israel well it's it's it's
twofold because let's be
clear Gaza and yehudin shamron you know
the West Bank that's in Israel so when
they say we want to return they mean we
want all the Jews to go or be removed so
that we can return to the rest of Israel
they are in Israel right now this land
that that they love so much and the
whole idea of the gazen
civilians being the Battleground itself
that's true that's been true always they
are Absolut they were kept as if as if
22 Arab Nations couldn't have absorbed
them 15 times over as if they couldn't
have had a state of their own as if this
had anything to do about any of the
things that we people pretend in the
media is their existence and their very
real suffering is 100% to be a um a
constant finger of accusation against
Israel um what do we
do with this information how do we
address it how how do we face it
well
um I I wish I had an answer to that I
mean you know uh I was just saying I
don't think that Israelis are really
aware of these things and I look at the
Netanyahu government and I think well
it's certainly better than the
Alternatives but he doesn't seem to have
any clearer understanding of this than
anybody else and then I see people say
the far-right government and the you
know all these things because he's a
little more aware of these realities
than other people but the fact is as you
noted you know Gaza and what is called
the West Bank they
they're not only are they historically
part of the land of Israel but
legally excuse me according to
international law they're part of the
land that was set aside by the League of
Nations and then Affirmed by the United
Nations to be the Jewish National home
so there really isn't any other country
that can take that can claim that it
owns this land and so it's supposed to
be occupied territory who occupied by
whom from whom and and there's so much
disinformation and misinformation around
there I suppose the only answer I can
give you to around these issues the only
answer I can give you to your question
of what can be done is to keep on
telling the truth and reminding people
of these things or
alerting people to these facts to try to
bring about political change in Israel
and the United States that might ease
the pressure on Israel to some
degree I think that's entirely true and
the fact that Israelis while there might
be
some again like we talked about those
sort of as it were isolated cases and
then the and then the massive invasion
that happened October 7th made it un
undeniable to us anymore so I think that
it was very important for us to
understand better the nature of what we
face but
ultimately whatever
negligence happened over the two years
that they were planning and we you want
to
believe it's so again different on an
elemental level this way of thinking
that again so many people who are happy
to either agree disagree or just never
see each other again so they can move on
with their lives and progress and go on
vacation now and then you know it's so
foreign it really actually you have to
keep on reminding yourself of it it's
very hard to keep in your head that this
is what we're dealing with of course now
we have absolutely no other option so um
I am just you have given me so much food
for thought I hope you'll come on again
and there's so much to learn and I think
that that's again I am a deep believer
in speaking the truth and I'm a believer
of of of being in con
constant learning and so um please come
back and and teach us more and of course
find you at Jihad watch tell us where to
find all of your books all all of your
writings yeah I am at jihadwatch.org and
that is uh the world's only news site
dedicated to giving you uh news about
Jihad activity in all its forms around
the world uh the war against Israel and
elsewhere and that's that jih a d
watch.org I have 28 books that you can
find at Amazon and at Barnes & Noble and
anywhere that books are sold uh or at
least you can ask them for it um the
book that I have there on the screen the
Palestinian delusion is subtitled the
catastrophic history of the Middle East
peace process and it is uh a fuller
explanation of many of the points that I
have made today so people might be
interested in uh picking up that one in
particular I was going to ask you that
what are the top three that that will
help us have a better understanding of
this period of time oh yeah well there's
the certainly the Palestinian delusion
and I have another book that I mentioned
earlier the history of jihad which takes
uh Jihad activity from the time of the
origins of Islam all the way up to the
present and also has of course a great
deal to do with Israel in the later
chapters because Israel is yet another
Jihad although it is not very often
identified as such and uh people may be
interested in uh books about the uh
basic ideology of Islam I suppose the
best one the fullest one is one the
critical Quran which is a uh clear
translation of the Quran plus commentary
to show you how it these passages are
understood in mainstream Islam and so it
also discusses Israel here and there and
shows what the Quran actually teaches
about the Jews as well as everything
else and shows the Wellsprings of the
tremendous hostility that we see from
the Islamic World toward Jews
today okay we're on it lots to learn
hopefully you'll come on again and I
wish you only well thank you so much
thank you
[Music]